[Music]
welcome to the heavy snyder show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who's been dying to break down
what zack snyder's army of the dead
entrails
in this video we're going to be going
through the full story of the movie
it's easter eggs and also the ending
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet then
sticking around for this video
is a great mistake however clicking the
thumbs up button if you enjoy the
breakdown isn't
and don't forget to subscribe as that's
a no-brainer like
a zombie who hasn't eaten in a while yes
the puns are terrible but without the
way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into army of the dead
okay so there's been a lot of
speculation over whether this movie is
connected to snyder's other zombie film
dawn of the dead whilst you can probably
draw your own head cannon over how the
films are linked
insider did come out with an interview
earlier in the week which cleared up a
lot of the confusion
now whilst there have been theories that
after the events of dawn the government
held on to a zombie who would later go
on to become the alpha zeus
snyder has stated that the movies aren't
connected whilst we know little of the
world before the events of the film
we will eventually get some answers as
netflix have already greenlit a prequel
which will follow the safe cracker
ludwig titled army of thieves
this movie actually finished filming in
december 2020
so we can probably expect to see it at
some point either towards the end of the
air or at the start of the next one
netflix have also greenland anime
television series called army of the
dead las vegas
which will follow some of the characters
from the movie and what they did in the
early stages of the outbreak
so we have a lot of things that will be
filling in character back stories
and potentially even the origin of the
alpha zombie zeus
maybe in doing all these spin-offs
they'll even find something to bring
joss whedon's career back from the dead
and i said oh you have a nata now that
kind of takes us to the opening of the
movie which follows the escape of the
aforementioned god of the dead
the creature has been kept underground
at area 51 for several years
and when the military transport him
across the desert he manages to break
free
after someone is getting brains and they
crash their car into the carrier
is getting brains a zombie pun i don't
know but we're leaving it in
any way now he kills almost all of the
soldiers there before setting his eyes
on the city of sin
to make one of the most unique settings
for a zombie movie this side of train to
bassan
the government quarantined the entire
location and i love how in the opening
montage we get a modern swing version of
beaver las vegas
you might remember that dawn of the dead
had a similar style with us getting a
swing version of down with the sickness
and i love that snyder carry this
aesthetic across to this movie
there's also a liberace impersonator who
is of course
playing on the famous entertainer that
often played in vegas
now in this crushing montage we are
introduced to several of the characters
including scott ward played by dave
bautista there's also omari hardwick who
plays van der rohe
and at one point in the film we see the
character has an omega symbol on his
chest
though this exudes power it's actually a
nod to snyder's other big release this
year
in which darkseid of course had the
symbol on his chest
and pretty much well everywhere now ward
tries to make a life for himself
outside of vegas but things are tough
however a deal that sounds too good to
be true comes along
in the form of tanaka a vegas casino
owner who wants him to break back into
the city
and steal over 200 million dollars from
his casino
the government plans to nuke vegas in
order to stop the outbreak
and thus there's a deadline for them to
rob zombie
thus he assembles the a team made up of
himself
mandaro ludwig dieter mikey guzman
chambers and helicopter pilot marianne
peters
played by if you've been following the
behind the scenes development on the
movie
then you'll know that chris delia was
originally in the film
but after the actor received several
allegations he was completely cgied out
of the movie
take replaced him and using green
screens santa had her dropped into the
film
knowing this i did expect to find it
slightly jarring at times
however i couldn't really spot the seams
and they did a really really good job
maybe next time that warner bros need to
digitally remove a mustache they can hit
these guys
because goddamn what a best are they the
film is very much playing on joseph
campbell's the hero's journey
which discusses how someone must travel
into the abyss to either discover
new things about themselves or treasures
campbell is even quoted in the film at
the end
and this archetype of the hero's journey
has been seen in several things
it's often also referred to as traveling
into the belly of the beast
and it has popped up in a number of
movies now speaking of movies i've
actually done some voiceover work for
amazon prime video
discussing all the things coming to the
platform in may and june
huge thank you to everyone who supported
the channel to the point that i get
offered opportunities like that and if
you want to check it out it will be
linked at the end
now tanaka's partner martin ends up
going along for the ride too
and they also get ward's daughter kate
early on it's revealed that scott had to
kill his wife and kate's mother during
the outbreak
and since then they haven't been on
speaking terms kate points them to
another who camp member called lily
and she too brings along a security
guard called burt played by theo rossi
who lily shades quite heavily now i love
how when they go through the plan
they make it seem easy peasy lemon
squeezy
definitely not squeezy but it's a lot
more difficult than that
in the plan montage there are some cool
little details and when they open the
safe there's a nice little snyder easter
egg
you can catch some canisters in the top
left corner and fans of the snyder cut
will of course know that these appeared
on snyder's vero as a way to show that
the cut actually existed
really nice little easter egg there and
probably my favorite in the movie
ludwig also has a spiked bat which might
be in onto negan from the walking dead
but that's probably a reach anyway scott
doesn't want kate going in
but after she learns that lilly
transported a woman in named guite who
has two kids on the outside
she decides that she will go in and save
her kate obviously knows what it's like
to lose her mother
and doesn't want the same thing to
happen to two other kids which is a
really nice little bit of character
development
that i appreciated now the team head in
and come across a zombie tiger
who of corpse belongs to siegfried and
roy the two vegas magicians
shortly after lily shoots cummings who
we learn has been
abusing the female workers and refugees
we discover that there are actually
several zombie types in the city
including shamblers which is a name that
you might have heard pop up in several
other zombie properties
like the last of us part 2. these are
your typical grunts
but they are led by what's known as the
alphas these highly intelligent members
of the undead
rule the landscape and if one is to
offer a sacrifice to them
they can grant safe passage that is
exactly what bird becomes
and he's taken by an alpha known as the
bride and one of her grunts
bird becomes infected by zeus and here
it's hinted that the bride
is pregnant later this is confirmed
showcasing that the undead have found a
way to reproduce
lily leads the group through the
landscape and throughout the city they
run into several members of the undead
it leads to the death of chambers after
she starts to suspect someone in the
camp has ulterior motives
though i don't know this for definite i
think that she might actually be a nod
to vasquez and aliens
and speaking of aliens we discovered
that like that movie
martin and well tanaka are working with
the government to find a way to
weaponize the undead
they want to create an army of the dead
and that very much becomes the main plot
of the movie
at bligh casino they separate into
specialist teams in order to complete
certain jobs
and take upon seeing the helicopter says
what a hunk of junk
which was said by luke skywalker upon
seeing the millennium falcon for the
first time
in the basement some team members
discover corpses of people wearing the
exact same clothes as they are
and though this isn't confirmed van der
rohe theorizes that it's them from
another timeline
stuck in an infinite loop of hell in
which they are all puppets being
manipulated by tanaka
it's a hilarious bit of meta commentary
that i think might be playing on sean of
the dead
i'm sure many people will debate for a
long time as to whether this entire
thing will just repeat over and over
guess i'm pressing the play button again
when this movie ends now
ward and kate stop the power and martin
and lily go to the perimeter
here they lure the bride out and manage
to behead her
it turns out that the head of an alpha
can be used to control the creatures
and it becomes the mcguffin over the
cache elsewhere we learned that the
deadline
hey sorry i already did that but the
nuke has been moved up
this gives them just over an hour to
break into the safe
but dida manages to do it kate sneaks
off to look for gita
and after being misled by martin lily
ends up swapping the bride's head with a
money counter and this comes into play
later on
zeus ends up taking the baby out of the
bride's body which could potentially be
a no to the birthing scene from snyder's
other zombie film
dawn of the dead the death of his love
puts him into a rage
and he sends his army after the group
which allows kate to get into his base
at the olympus casino ward and crews
decide to go look for her
but a breakneck twist happens when she's
killed by zeus's forces
as they swarm martin ends up blocking
the team in the basement
and zeus arrives bandaro tries to go toe
to toe with him
and no we don't see this happen it is
revealed at the end of the movie that he
was bit during this
dida sacrifices himself and that's why
we're getting a prequel with the
character
and not a sequel he locks the character
in the vault
and outside of martin comes face to face
with the tiger
who treats him like leo in the revenant
in the casino
ward and koa swarmed by shamblers and
after being bit
guzman sacrifices himself with
explosives which
wipe out most of the horde as well as
the money now i don't know if i'm seeing
things here but there was a shot where
it looked like one of the zombies was
actually a robot
i did some research on this and it turns
out that there's a theory that the
government were actually trying to
create android zombies
before they settled on zeus we know that
zeus also comes from area 51 and there
is apparently a ufo at the start of the
movie
so lots of theories you can have over
how the outbreak started
the survivors travel to the roof and are
confronted by zeus and lily holds up the
bride's head to distract the beast
giving scott time to get to the cha-pa
so by now lily is impaled but she
manages to destroy the bride's head
before zeus takes her at olympus kate
finds guida
but zombie bird shows up and bites one
of the survivors
zeus then arrives and sends his forces
after her but luckily
scott shows up to save the day they rush
to the roof only to find that peters has
deserted them
which could be another nod to bishop in
aliens not being at the landing platform
when ripley rescues newt
zeus jumps in the chopper with the
survivors as the nuke arrives
echoing the ending of resident evil 3 in
which jill was saved by barry as the
government fired a missile at raccoon
city
scott manages to kill zeus but
unfortunately the shock wave from the
nuke causes the helicopter to crash
we can see that zeus's blood is also
blue further tying back to the robot
and also the alien theory which i'm
gonna have some fun with i tell you
kanaka watches the news coverage and
looks at his phone
knowing that martin didn't manage to get
ahead at this point
kate very much is put in the position
that scott was when it came to his wife
and her mother
as he's very much going to turn into a
zombie unless she acts
fast she must kill the person she loves
in order to be safe
and scott of course had to kill the
woman he did so that kate would be okay
it's kind of like poetry they rhyme and
ward gives kate some of the money so
that she can start a new life
before he changes she kills him before a
helicopter arrives to pick her up
and it's a really devastating moment for
the character now we cut to van der rohe
who climbs out of the wreckage after
going to the indiana jones school of how
to survive a nuke
this guy doesn't get radiation poisoning
and he drags himself across the desert
to the song zombie by the cranberries
the character drives to utah and then
gets a private plane to mexico city
he has a toast with the air hostesses
and starts to feel funny
which is where he discovers that he was
bitten in the fight earlier
i'm guessing that ward changed far
quicker than he did because he was close
to death
and due to him starting to feel unwell
he's now going to end up becoming a
zombie himself
now this opens up a lot of possibilities
and when i was speaking to my editor
christine at beyond epic
he did say that you could have the head
cannon that this starts off the dawn of
the dead
personally i think that he will actually
go on to become the new alpha
and that this will start an outbreak in
mexico city
the movie works really well because this
could just simply be self-contained
but there is also a lot of room for
sequels van der rohe could end up going
world war z on the plane
and when they arrive in mexico city it
could unleash a new zombie uprising
alpha and omega are sayings that mean
the beginning and the end
and with van der rohe having a tattoo of
the latter it could mean that he is
going to go on to become the next form
of the zombie
i think that works really really well
and is set up earlier in the movie
and yeah that's just what i'd love to
see next time that could potentially tie
into a sequel
and though as of this video we haven't
had anything greenlit yet
the wall street journal posted an
article saying that netflix is planning
on fixing its film franchise issue with
army of the dead
so far they don't really have a 10-pole
film series that you can really connect
with them
and the streaming service is apparently
going to launch a lot of things from
this
i definitely think we will get a sequel
and after zach was messed around so much
by warner bros
it's nice he's found somewhere that
actually want to give him free reign
the other film was a lot slower paced
than i expected
i really enjoyed it and it was far more
character-based than i thought
i really didn't expect this to be a
popcorn action movie but there's a lot
of subtle moments here
and it's a far different film to what i
thought we were going to be getting
i know the movie is getting criticism
for being very blurry at points
personally i like that snider was trying
out a new style
and thought that the movie was shot
really well snyder is at his best when
he's not restricted by runtime or
studios trying to force his vision to be
a certain way
and whilst i don't think that people who
don't already like his work will be one
around
those that do will have a lot of fun
here this was a blast with a really fun
premise
i'm looking forward to seeing more of
overall i think army of the dead is the
one to watch this weekend
and it gets an 8 out of 10. obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
film
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you want something else to
watch and
want to know what's coming to amazon
prime video over the next couple of
months
then that video is linked right on
screen now without the way
thank you for sitting through this
breakdown i've been paul and hopefully
i'll see on the next one
take care peace